What is the role of perfectionism
in language learning?
That's my subject today, and
I want to look at it from
four different points of view.
Why would we want to pursue perfection?
Where is it more important
to pursue perfection?
When, at what stage in our
language learning should we try to
pursue improvement or perfection?
And fourth, how do we go about
improving or pursuing that
elusive goal of perfection?
Upfront, we are unlikely
to achieve perfection.
So pure perfectionism is
out of place and counterproductive
in language learning.
However, the desire to constantly
improve is an important part of
motivation in language learning.
And I think that's a major reason
why the pursuit of perfection,
even if we don't achieve it, has
its place in language learning.
It's a natural thing
to want to get better.
So you're working for a company in
English or German or Japanese, and
you're sending out correspondence.
You can't make too many mistakes.
It reflects badly on you and on
the company you're working for.
Certainly preparing for tests is an area
where we try to be better because language
instruction teaches us to be afraid
of mistakes, even though in reality.
People who are more adventurous
in their use of the language
may make more mistakes, but
they're going to achieve more.
They're going to communicate better.
So it's a bit of
a double-edged sword.
If we're too hung up about making
mistakes, we won't progress in
the language, but obviously tests,
professional situations, and a natural
desire to want to improve are all reasons.
To pursue perfection.
So then the question is, where do
we want to work towards perfection?
The most, the area that most people
seem to be concerned about when it
comes to being overly self critical
or wanting to be better or wanting
to be perfect is pronunciation.
And to me, that is the least important,
as long as you're able to be understood.
Then that's good enough.
There is a very low likelihood
that language learners will
end up sounding like a native.
You can maybe try to improve, but
you're going to be less than perfect.
You should accept it.
So perfectionism in pronunciation
to me is the least important.
At the other end of the spectrum,
things like spelling are very
important because if you're writing.
And particularly if you're working
for a company or you're writing
in university, spelling mistakes
reflect very badly on the writer.
Now, fortunately today, much of
our writing is on a computer, so
we are able to check the spelling.
However, a lot of mistakes slip through.
And so I think it's important to focus
on spelling as an area where we, if not
perfect, we need to be very, very good.
Now, in between those two extremes,
pronunciation and spelling, we
have things like grammar and
the related idea of word usage.
To me, word usage, natural word usage is
more important than details of grammar.
But both of those, I think we
can be a little more permissive.
Even in business communication, as long
as the meaning is clear, I think there
is less of a demand for perfection
than say, in the case of spelling,
the same holds for punctuation.
So at what stage in our language
learning should we be more concerned
about our accuracy or our perfectionism?
Very definitely, I think we should
be more focused on being perfect or
less inaccurate at a later stage.
Upfront, any pressure on the learner to
produce correctly is counterproductive.
Most people give up because they're
frustrated, because they feel they're
not doing well or they're not learning.
And so any additional pressure at
the early stage is counterproductive.
I do not believe that fossilized.
The brain is naturally developing this
model of the language, anticipating the
language, helping us create utterances
in the language, drawing on things that
it has stored in its long term memory.
All of this takes time to accumulate.
So at a later stage in the language,
when we want to really improve certain
aspects where we know we're, we're
not doing as well as we would like.
It's never too late.
I don't believe that if a
person is motivated to improve.
That the mistakes they make at the early
stage are going to be with them and that
they'll never be able to improve them.
I simply don't believe that.
So less emphasis on getting things
right, mastering the basics, all
of these things up front, more
latitude for mistakes early on.
Encourage the learner, encourage
yourself, and then later on, when
you're a little more comfortable in
the language, you can go back in and
sort of clean up the, uh, rough edges.
So then if we say that it's
legitimate to want to constantly
improve, but it's highly unlikely
that we're ever going to be perfect.
So perfectionism per se is out.
How do we continue improving?
And here, I think it's obvious that
it takes time to learn a language.
So therefore the way to work
towards perfection is simply to
keep going, to enjoy the language.
To not worry about how we're
doing, not worry about mistakes.
In fact, we learn from our mistakes to
forget and relearn and forget and relearn.
That's how things are then
anchored in our long term memory.
And that's how we end up with.
Words and phrases that
we can comfortably use.
My advice is don't worry
about being perfect.
Try to get in the flow of the experience
of discovering a new language.
And I think you'll be surprised at how
you continue to progress towards, if not
perfection, at least constant improvement.
And I will leave you with two
videos on related subjects.
One that talks about perfectionism.
And another one that talks
about the importance of making
mistakes in language learning.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.